attention attention bozos and homies we
got the card game for sale which is
running out and we also got some live
dates that just keep on trucking gang
the card game is running out we're
running out of supplies do yourself a
favor act now pick up the card we're
never making it again it's the last time
we're making this Edition so do yourself
a favor pick up a pack let's go uh yeah
guys we also uh this month in November
we have two shows in Atlanta one sold
out early tickets still left for the
early show and then we're going to
Charlotte North Carolina get those
tickies Philadelphia two shows are sold
out we got some tickets left in
Providence on the second show get those
tickets and Boston's about to sell out
if you're in if you're in Beantown let's
go let's party do it gang we love you
gang this episode is brought to you by
our good friends at established titles
with established titles you can buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land and you yourself can be a lord or a
lady it's a fun way to preserve the
Scottish Woodlands with every order
established plants a tree and works with
global charities to support Global
reforestation efforts that's all well
and good but be [__] cool become a
Lord that's what I'm saying yeah I mean
the tree cool that's gravy on top but
you can become a lord gives you at least
uh like you said one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland official certificate
with a Crest peep this one hit him with
the close-up uh makes an amazing last
minute gift established titles is
actually running an early Black Friday
sale plus if you use code garbage you'll
get an additional 10 off go to establish
titles.com to get your gifts now and
help support the channel do it yeah
welcome so another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out the
group to be classy or if they're just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day it's Halloween down here in Aunt
tutty's basement you ain't lying she's
upstairs loading up the cooler giving
away four Locos this year all right make
sure you stop by Tony's early kids
because the watermelon ones are gonna go
quick my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he's dressed like Sam Elliott
for Halloween give it up for KJ James
Ryan what's up gang I knew I was gonna
catch [__] on this uh I bought it in
Europe all right I'm trying to expand my
horizons because the Dickies in Europe
yeah it was trash it was discount too
not bragging I got my Carhartt from
Milan
it only cost them three cougars your
thought is I went all the way to Europe
and where High fashion is and I bought
tickets fair enough uh guys make sure
you rate if you subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [__] out gang it's a party over
there yeah it was a solid King having a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones and twos
crosses the t's and dots the eyes give
it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dude what's
up speaking of bone you got a unit I can
see it for me you didn't know that he's
got a Honda legendary I cannot look at
it well I don't need to say anything
else sorry sorry got that big old
sausage oh yeah bone in
holy hell [__] Tomahawk Jones over
here yeah right gang we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly specials
that was a comic in the 70s it was a
native American now he'd go Hi how are
you Hi how are you yeah yeah Carson
where'd it go there's a good bet then
it's a good bit now it still works sorry
zombie silly ladies called The Guardian
all right we could now people were
excited to have more incredibly special
guests back with us again today he's
family at this point number five maybe
four or five well you're up there you
know him from we might be drunk you know
from Tuesdays with stories he's all over
the place got a theater tour kicking off
baby out there doing theaters pick up a
couple of ticks marknormancomedy.com
ladies and gentlemen give it up Mark
Norman everybody look at him
came in look looking tight when you came
in too thank you I did a pull-up on a
scaffolding like a real mooc
gets the blood pumping you know I make
what are those pants you're wearing
they're like they seem expensive no they
were a gift I got them uh in Europe they
were a gift from Chubbies Chubbies will
throw away some free clothes and that's
Leisure wear I believe it's called thank
you salvacano put us onto that Chubbies
huh really like the sound of that notice
like the guys who would work the least
wear the most like leisury [__] yeah you
know it's tracksuit just velor it's a
bathrobe these guys aren't doing [__] I
know I that's why like it's a mental
thing for me like if I don't put on a
pair of jeans and something I feel like
I'm not working right I'm like I gotta
be a little bit uncomfortable in a pair
of jeans if I'm too comfortable in
sweatpants I feel like the biggest piece
of [__] you know you see these queefs in
the airport they're full it's crazy dude
with the Crocs on they got the hood up
and a pillow you're sitting next to one
over here put a pair of denim I'm
currently wearing uh shorts short pajama
sleepers it's bad with Crocs with no
shoes look at those they're Crocs with
no socks got some Gams over here some
ham rocks baby this is a Penn Station
outfit right here
all he needs is a pair of alligator
shoes to go with it Dunkin Donuts
sandwich out of the bag
now here's I got no spots tonight and
I'm going back to clean my apartment so
I wanted to stay in the so you showed up
to work like a homeless guy yeah plus I
have no clothes you're dressed for a
call for help dude oh man I do look like
a jumper don't I I think a 10 o'clock
jumper on the GW Bridge I heard you're
on the weight loss game now all right
trying I heard you're trying I don't
know I am trying mark thank you very
much no he's not check out that
patreon.com for updates oh sorry I
didn't mean to bring it I went I went
dropped about 30 and then I went up
about 20. so I'm trying to go back down
again that was yesterday
damn you talk about weight like a casino
I'm up I'm up right now
they switched dealers I got screwed
Pit Boss give me the eye
it's a Barbecue Pit Boss
so it's got a heater already though
playing with rib bones
he loves chips
I do like chips
that's good Halloween yes you got that
right no candy corn please
candy Corn's the worst that's crazy talk
yuck chalky waxy gross I don't mind it
in very small a hand like a one Handful
in this season that'll be it I love it
here I love it I like the pumpkins too
the Candy Corn pumpkins those are better
the whole nine yards I'm all about it
what did you what did you do as a kid
for a house you had like a traditional
house to house it wasn't a great
neighborhood right no we lived in a
rough area so we'd go to my friend's
house in the suburb and the parents
would kind of lag 10 feet behind sure
they would all skip to the lou with our
little land uh jack-o-lanterns although
I did a schwegman's bag which is our
grocer okay plastic bag or yeah grocery
bag double bagged and uh you know you
you Dre I always did the I dressed up
too late and just would put something on
one time I put on a vest and my friend's
like what are you I'm like I'm a spy
I'm a gay spy obviously yeah
what was your bet do you remember your
best one of like maybe your mom in it
out of the park or for whatever reason
your splurged a couple of bucks well
remember this is the late 80s early 90s
so I did a couple uh a couple Native
Americans that was big bad you could buy
that at the store at the time though
that's not your fault totally with the
full feather and everything scalp
the bow and arrow too yeah a little dark
uh so but then the the big one was the
uh the Ghost with the sheet but you're
so close to Clan
especially in the South that's a bad
look yeah he's picked the wrong turn
yeah but uh it was fun I mean Halloween
was huge just the free the idea of
anything free giving away to Children
was huge yeah and also down there too
don't they really get into that [__] the
real like oh we're very spooky yeah and
and also pre-internet we had a couple
houses on uh on our route to school that
would really go hard
I'm talking skeletons in the front yard
and they would name the one they would
be like uh here lies Jenkins or whatever
no but it would be puns I'm trying to
think of a good one like uh uh [__] hold
on we just give me give me a celebrity
Al Trebek all right uh give me a
location Joan Rivers Joan Rivers Joe
it'd be bone Rivers
Mozart yeah Henry Kissinger
yeah Alex sure
whatever happened to him he died
we're getting old oh yeah we are I was
sad about uh the guy Leslie you know
Leslie a little guy yeah no I didn't
know I can't think of his last name the
gay guy he was in uh Will and Grace
uh and then he got big on like Tick Tock
started cooking on uh Instagram and
stuff over the pandemic he's doing
Little Voices yeah you know what we're
talking about yeah yeah I think I know
you're talking about Norm Macdonald had
the great point about uh he's like it's
weird that Will and Grace is like this
Progressive show but every time they
talk about being gay the crowd laughs
you know so I hooked up with a man last
night I was like ah yeah cute laughter
yeah how is that not offensive yeah
they're laughing at the wrong thing yeah
yeah Norm the game whatever happened to
that guy
to Norm yeah Halloween we we do
appreciate the ladies with the uh the
Rory outfits in college that was the
[__] best dude a freshman in college
that really [__] blew your head off
every first Halloween party you went to
you're like what the [__] when it was
fresh too I feel like they didn't really
unless it's just you know
the way I see it that that didn't really
start until we were getting of age that
really blew up I gotta remember as a kid
seeing like I don't think in the 60s and
70s they were dressing up as like hori
nurse maybe they were I don't know some
there was probably one girl yeah he was
the Jackie Robinson yeah
right shout out to that dumb more yeah
good for her and it just started to move
because other girls go when she now
she's looking hotter than me
it was able to do like the baseball
outfit it was like literally just every
that was like the big joke it was like
whatever the hori version of anything
and they made it work it was awesome oh
yeah sexy uh zombie Martha Washington
whatever yeah sexy vampire the big I got
fired once off a gig there's a whole
side story but I'll make it quick now
make it long I got a Halloween gig
somebody's like we saw at the comedy
Center we like your irreverent edgy
attitude whatever the [__] and it's some
exec and he hired me to host a Halloween
costume costume contest on AOL it was a
big deal they're gonna stream it back
when streaming was like a big thing AOL
AOL is five grand was the most fun I
ever seen in my life we want you to
judge the Halloween costume contest and
I go you got it full audience and they
go be edgy I go great so uh this uh
African queen comes on oh boy sexy and
whatever and then as she's walking off
Catwoman walks on you know hot lady with
the tight skin and she's whipping and I
go hey watch that whip around the
African I mean the camera is builted
though the Lights Went Out you hear the
power cut I got fired immediate
[Laughter]
is way different than an AOL edgy
exactly sure you know did you do
Mischief night when you were a kid would
you get into trouble yeah that was big
big time we always got caught too we we
egged a house and we ran home and they
just saw the house we went in ding dong
and the mom yelled at us what did you
call we've talked about this I don't
know if we haven't done in a while what
did you call when you wouldn't knock on
the door and run away oh we called it a
ding dong and run or something like that
there was ding dong ditch ding dong
ditch that's it there was a really bad
one the worst Asian porn star by the way
you know her
okay I like our work yeah
um knock knock zoom zoom people would
say as a kid and it's just that's [__]
[__] it's not gonna run stupid knock
knock zoom zoom no yeah which sounds it
doesn't make any sense no what do you
guys call uh dine and dash dine and dash
wasn't there another there's another one
never did it eat and run there was
another one you're right he's gonna like
big dicks BD he's using his penis on the
computer by the way we had the hot guy
in our group he was ripped and he would
go as a baby every year
got the teachers all over
great uh David tell line Halloween or as
I call it the Super Bowl for pedophiles
ah man he's good he's pretty good that
guy
dude some of these are [__] terrible
oh yeah chew and Skidoo oh my God it's
fun though that's gotta be Canadian
that's
got real Saskatchewan here it's two inch
can do man I left that Duty tip and dip
that ain't bad tip and dips all right
that's not great because you're still
tipping yeah this one's just a shot of
foot Penn State style I don't know wow
Krampus Shaker High School flutter Dash
I thought that was a famous one I'm
forgetting I think Diamond Dash is the
most did you do that on everything I did
it like twice and felt horrible about it
yeah one time I left my jacket so I felt
like that was a sign did you have to go
back yeah I went back you did put on
blackface
a white kid stole my jacket you see it
anywhere in here yeah they're always
stealing our culture sorry that my body
tried at one time is drunk and he like
went in by himself and like sat down ate
had a beer or two and was like all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I know
where the back door is gonna make a run
on the back door but in his drunken
stupidness he made a right instead of a
left and ended up in the kitchen
he was just cornered and he was like all
right I'll pay himself that's a great I
would just pick up a dish yeah you got
me one of my one of my greatest
victories in life was I was uh I was
waiting tables at this place in Murray
Hill this is before I did comedy when I
lived up here the first time I was at a
real low point a lot of drugs [__] by
myself it was bad situation yeah I'm
working their St Patrick's Day oh
there's two [__] douchebags in there
one of them's wearing a kilt oh boy they
sit down they eat they're drinking
they're getting up they're going to the
bar this and that's starting to fill in
at night for the [__] St Patrick's
Day blah blah blah blah blah they asked
for the check the one guy goes to the
bathroom and this one [__] [__]
that was that was wearing The Kilt just
bolts out the door and he bolts out that
this is so I'm on the corner of 30th
between second and first so he bolts out
the door and he goes around down 2nd
Avenue towards 29th Street so I'm like
[__] this I just I was [__] so mad
yeah I go out and I go the other way and
[__] just hoping I was like I'll be
back in [__] five minutes [__] run
out run the other way [__] catch him
running down the street and just [__]
close I love a good clothes [__] grab
them and this guy should have been able
to kick my ass he was like [__] stick
something sure but I think just the
[__] anger and the [__] whatever
[__] clotheslined him grab them
[__] drug them back to the [__]
Barn okay yeah somebody's like these
guys beating up that trans woman
what's that that kid doing yeah it felt
great well two two things there one if
you're gonna get away The Kilt you're
[__] because that's not it's obvious
yeah yeah yeah two that's not even Irish
Scottish so he's got the wrong holiday
[__] douchebag you were his William
Wallace baby I didn't see you coming at
all
I try to once when me and my buddy were
day drinking early and then is in New
York went to like a nice place I always
wanted to find it was like a hotel I
think it's called like the Marlton Hotel
down in the West Village like maybe like
9th Street or something like that oh I
know the spot it might be the Marlton
Hotel you walk it's like real cozy
you're dying to dash there no we I had
gone there on a date before and I was
like I know this nice I know this real
fancy place yeah great I know where all
the cameras are yeah I cased The Joint
it's like heat
so I forgot the blueprints don't worry
we'll be all right we're sitting there
and the bartender was being a [__]
jerk off and it was just me and my buddy
in there and he was like making us we
were the only two at the bar he was
making us wait for drinks and just being
rude so I texted my buddy like yo let's
[__]
I was we were wasted I'm like let's you
know let's [__] get out of here dude
let's just run not don't pay this guy
really yeah and he's like all right so I
was like this is recently yeah I mean a
couple of years ago holy [__] I don't
know about this yeah but this is more
about sticking it to the douche than it
is about no pay yeah this is [__] this
guy this guy was being the biggest
[__] and you know I'm typically very
good to servers and everything like that
but I was like [__] this guy and I was
like all right let's get out of here and
I guess he heard us planning and he
turns he's like you guys are gonna think
about running out are you we're like no
sir I swear to God here's a million
dollars have a nice night
it's funny I did that once that's too
scary not that long I don't dude they
got the could have a gun
they're crazy what do you call that
thing that extends that uh what's on
yeah oh those things yeah that's
Scorpion from Mortal Kombat
no like the Blackjack type yes
take a tooth out real quick yeah I did
it I think right before the pandemic do
you remember yeah your card got declined
yeah my card got declined I was [__]
[__] up broke in a cab about a block
away from my apartment in Queens and I
think I I think I mentioned this on a
patreon episode and I really fluffed it
up that like I didn't know and you knew
your car I knew exactly what was going
on yeah had my kilt on and everything
getting ready to Boogie and um I was in
one of those square ones the square cabs
that have the the sliding the door yeah
yeah and we I had him stop on uh a block
away from my apartment and I like put
the card in and I try to get out he's
like he's like yeah the car didn't go
through I'm like nah nah I went through
man
and then I just [__] Bolt it wow now
at the time I'm about 425 pounds oh my
Lord this guy I was running it's bolted
in you know in context he wasn't he
wasn't breaking any records I did a
couple of quick zigzags you know what I
mean little [__] I went into beast
mode real quick and this guy I'm running
up the street and this guy is going
backwards in the car right next to me
[__] had me dead with the back door
open laughing his ass off oh neck and no
neck
he's like where the [__] do you think
you're going I thought I was really
doing it man wow he was right there with
me and then I just got to a certain
point where I think he didn't give a
[__] and just just pulled away you got
out of it I got out of it whoa yeah and
then I I literally ran and guy got into
my door of my apartment and I collapsed
in the lobby like literally like all
over 14 I could not move I had exerted
that much energy damn he did a
cheeseburger or something to bring me
back up but then the next morning
remember I woke up and I I tried to find
the guy I tried to look at my receipt in
the cab and all that stuff and I was
never able to find them it's tough yeah
uh Gary veter say what you will he's
four foot one you know the Jews yeah but
uh Kanye yeah there you go uh we were in
a cab once and he accidentally tipped on
his card a hundred dollars and it was
like a ten dollar ride and he
accidentally tipped sure 100 and so now
it's a hundred and ten dollars and he's
like whoa whoa it was I meant to give
you like two bucks I [__] up and the
guy's like well you know what can you do
this is like a whole language barrier
and he's like I can't I don't know how
you know he was bullshitting and Gary's
like I'm not getting out of this car
until you give me my money and he's like
I can't the computer or whatever and I
was we both had a spot we're at New York
time we go right outside and he's like
I'm not getting out I'm like you're
gonna miss your spot I'm out of the car
at this point like in the window like
dude you're on yeah I did his time came
out he's still there I leave I texted
like an hour later still in the car and
I was like all right get out here's
here's I'll erase it yeah because at
that point you're costing he's losing
money I'm like I can't I could go make
this money yeah I gotta get going here
exactly I like that tough little guy he
was in that booster seat for an hour
nobody unhook them
got his little wheel in the peepee okay
let's talk about Helix baby Helix baby I
mastered baited and won earlier today
let's talk about getting a good night's
sleep not naughty stuff gang you don't
want to be getting your mattress at a
mattress store with some Bozo with bad
breath all right doesn't talk short
sleeve button up looking like a bozo
kids don't look him in the eye you want
to go over to Helix you want to take the
quiz you want to get the perfect
mattress that fits you at Helix sleep
baby yeah if you sleep hot if you sleep
cold if you're a big guy whatever you
need they got you squared up take the
two minute sleep we've been pushing this
for years they're fantastic I'm on one
baby I've owned two in my life they're
that good you take the two minute sleep
quiz me and my lady we got the Twilight
mattress fantastic sprung for the king
easy peasy comes uh Helix knows there's
no better way to test out a new mattress
uh than to sleep on it there you go so
they offer a hundred night risk free
trial you try it out your new Helix
mattress see how your body adjusts if
you decide it's not the best fit for you
you're welcome to a full refund look at
that guy that's good business that's why
that Helix is going to be around for a
while that's what they call a no worry
guarantee yes for sure uh Helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners two go to helixsleep.com
garbage one more time heelsleep.com
garbage with Helix better sleep starts
now do it do it KB let's talk about
butcher box baby gobble gobble let's do
it let's talk about the holiday season
coming up and you want to get a top
quality turkey don't you yeah so you
don't want to be picking it up at Pep
Boys or whatever the rest of the bozos
are getting it you want a top quality
turkey from butcher box and I'll tell
you this right now this is Off Script I
just I I I just got a shipment coming to
you yeah yeah I love that I got the 50
pound turkey coming I'm gonna be showing
up everybody Thanksgiving they sent me
everything I'm not even joking my wife's
making a goulash right now with us with
a rib eye they sent over I can't wait to
get home it's a good time over there at
that butcher box and it's turkey season
and you want to get the best top quality
turkey that you possibly can and I
promise you you're only going to get
that at butcher box guys uh the main
course for Thanksgiving dinner can
sometimes be a main source of stress not
anymore thanks to the good Folks at bee
box put your boxes offering our
listeners free turkey with their first
order baby sign up today at
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg to get one 10 to 14
pound turkey free in your first box
you're covered what I would do I would
join get it have the turkey now then get
another turkey later Bubble Up on the
turkey that's butcherbox.com cyg and use
the code ayg to claim this deal doing it
does let's all even out a little bit
like I did I felt like a piece of [__]
for doing that I usually never do stuff
like that I think I was just hemmed up
at the time yeah but it does even out I
had one one time where I would go to
this this place all the time I was
working in Philly at a Macy's and during
my lunch break I'd go to this there was
like this sports bar and I would go get
like you know a sandwich and a Diet Coke
or whatever I got chicken fingers and
fries life in the fastest
really batting them away with this
working at a boss cops I was in college
all right musk he must have been peeling
them off yeah wearing my dad's suit too
it was bad man real bad wait what was
the occasion no as I was working at
Macy's I had to wear a suit he was a
loser
it was a loser day at Hooters
but so I ordered whatever it was like
say it was 12 bucks I tipped like you
know whatever four bucks or whatever and
I left and the [__] waiter I left the
blank receipt and how they give you one
for you and one for that yeah yeah I
left the blank one
and he filled in I forgot the number
like 500 bucks or something what instead
of five dollars I made a 500. so I woke
up accounts overdrawn by like a million
dollars alarms are going off right so I
wake up like panicked and uh the suit's
gone I go to [__] it my dad's pissed
okay
I I I'm like [__] this I'm going in yeah
there's like champ sports grill or
whatever and I I go in
they closed that day that was their last
day in business so he knew and like I
walked up boarded up closed up out of
business I was like [__] you got me it
was intentional yeah I kind of respect
the chest of it all of hey man [__] you
got to be a real piece of [__] as a
server to do that yeah I waited tables
for so long and I always wanted to do it
because some people were [__] real
dicks but never did you always got to
take that other receipt or crumple it I
always I haven't never I still take it
with me every single time never thought
about that and make sure dollar signs
fill up the rest of the line whoa don't
just do it five and leave it in the you
put your own dollar sign in there right
holy yeah I'm a cash guy I'm all cash
you do cash for the tip even if the
meals on the card yep really yeah you
can write off the meal but you just
tipping cash huh and I think they like
it too yeah that's a very that's a very
it's old school yeah it's a very old mom
thing to do oh is that Mom oh my mom
does I'll give it they want it in case
give a doom in case see my mom's the
opposite she was the checkbook [__]
yeah she would go to the grocery store
hang on there's a [__] line out of
the door I was a cashier's man this is I
was a cashier to at a supermarket for a
long time and people would break out the
[__] channel it's all credit and
debit it's all credit debit barely any
cash all credit debit this is two
thousand you know four or five or
whatever and somebody would come with a
checkbook yeah take like nine minutes I
know nine minutes yeah forms of ID this
whole thing kick rocks crazy that they
do that you could also cash your checks
at the bank can't you or at the grocery
grocery store does Check Cashing yeah
you want to talk trash she would do the
coupon she was a coupon [__] too she
would be clipping all morning really oh
yeah I yeah go in there and load up huh
yeah and she'd be like look at that I
saved 11 cents you're like that was a
that was two hours yeah you know and you
bought something only because you had
the coupon you didn't necessarily I
wasn't on the list to begin with right
now you got four gallons of olive oil
yeah we're not going to use lemon lime
Pine salt what are you doing let's go
right yeah I hated that man people come
in with I get it if you're you know if
you're trying to trying to save a buck I
get it you know got a family what are
you gonna do of course but some people
also like the juice they like that they
like the they like that the Russian
couponing or whatever yeah yeah and
bringing it back to Halloween we used to
get a free icy whoa coupon that's pretty
good you guys have icees yeah yeah same
yeah yeah I mean I see the the polar
bear yeah
free there was a coupon so the lady
would throw it in and you're kind of
like oh what's this an IOU for a
Snickers but no it was uh I like that oh
they would give that to you yeah then
you go to the the 7-Eleven and they were
like all right go nuts that's not bad my
mom one year really killed it for a
couple years she gave away cans of soda
she got a huge [__] fattest [__] I've
ever heard she got a huge cooler iced it
down Cherry Cokes Cokes Pepsis I'm
telling you man the kids loved it
because they would hit that house if it
was a seasonably warm right Halloween
you hit that house you got a Screaming
Mimi Cherry Coke waiting for you that's
all right that is good how about the
Patty there's no beverages on Halloween
never you're dying good point speaking
about my dad my dad and all the other
dads would drive behind like you know
how like slowly behind they'd be like oh
we're a couple houses yeah
everybody in the car there would be five
or six dads of an SUV or minivan yeah
just slugging beers
can we say that with Patton told us oh
yeah wasn't a bit or anything was it no
no I was talking to Sean Patton at skank
Fest his family they wouldn't give him a
bag he would just they yeah crazy in
between houses
[Laughter]
holy [__] how crazy is that wow
dude wow you get diabetes by the end of
the night that's insane because you
don't want to waste it I like it yeah
you don't want to I like the idea but I
was too much of a little fat kid hoarder
that I wanted to have the candy yeah and
I wanted to we talked about break
everything out it's a savings account
checking account split it up start make
it stop cutting deals right get rid of
that peanut candy what was that thing
the shape of the peanut yeah it's like a
packing piece oh circus peanuts
[Applause]
those things are from like the 17th of
the infidels I'll be honest with you but
I like a circus peanut yeah what would
you what would be your parents Vig my
mom was my mom would dip in it again
yeah Snickers is what they would take my
mom would take say my dad was a
chocolate douche so he would just pop
over the uh the Reese's Reese's was my
number one he won the cup crazy with the
gold wrapping oh that was bad a little
one I think is a better ratio to
chocolate peanut butter that's crazy
talk oh yeah I'm telling you a fresh
thing really a fresh single a fresh
singles where the one side is a little
more chocolate than the other and it has
that bite no no I want equality I wanna
in a race commercial take it easy AOC
way
do you remember the commercial where
they put the hole in the middle of the
single but it was like yes it was it
might have been like Macaulay call it
was like a famous actor I feel that was
doing the commercial I could be wrong
Will Arnett does them now but really try
to get the circle was like every kid
tried to like knock out the zigzag yeah
I was just [__] licking buttholes
that's how it started but I feel like on
the mini ones The Ridges were a little
crunchier I'll give you that was a
crunchier bite for sure for sure
crunchier there was a crunchy one for a
minute wasn't there wasn't there a
potato chip in it now buddy no yeah yeah
yeah what do you don't try to get them
hard what are we doing here
I already came across it about eight
months ago
I came across it about eight months ago
and it's not just you know it's in a big
one it's in the big cup okay which are
wild that's the lot that's like a speed
ball you know when they put the greases
pieces in a cup holy [__] killed Belushi
that's too much yeah the chip is is wild
The Salty The Salty and the sweet man I
really missed a boat on that yeah as far
as my fat tenure it seems like you're
making up for it so we're all good here
everything checks out
all right what about the wedding talk
tell us about that you're getting
hitched congratulations getting hitched
and the lady of course started out with
the old uh hey we're gonna keep it light
keep it simple keep it small and now
it's just full blown all out ticker tape
or haven't have any references to the
ticker tape but it's just all in we got
a second line we got a huge band we got
crazy food it's gonna be nuts we're
is she from down there too no but she's
from uh Boston so we figure it's a
little more fun gotcha okay let me just
fighting too maybe not actually New
Orleans you got the full band full but
we got the Saints band the band who
plays opens for the Saints Jesus I don't
like power too now you know what I mean
yeah that's true that's true we got some
big uh big hitters who's uh who's the
biggest going if you don't mind me
asking well I asked to tell and he was
incredibly touched but I got the funny
bone yeah I can't imagine he would take
off for uh something or have a suit I
would assume
Ian's is plus one Ian's gotta do five
minutes
he got me a pack of Marlboros smoked he
would show up with like two suit jackets
all right right yeah from like uh what
is it toys for what's the cars for kids
no the homeless coats uh the the coat
drives the yeah
yeah there's a wallet for coats I don't
know coat hobo cover the hobo I don't
know
but I'm telling you this is a hobo coat
drive
one warm coat ah maybe not New York
Cares coat drive ah forget it I think
they're just called coach I don't know
maybe Burlington Coat Factory there you
go with that we'll cut all this make us
all look good
got it ah cut it print it all right so
you don't think it tells gonna show no
and then I threw it at Rogan but I don't
want I feel bad asking these big guys
because I don't want them to think I
just want their star power sure I don't
like them as people of course but I
didn't ask Jerry yeah I mean come on
that would just be like a uh really it
was I would like I would I would like a
nice gift from Jared though
he's probably the classy kind of guy
that's gonna send the gift anyway I'm
not going to that but here send a gift
that's what Rich guys do they send you
yeah send a gift in my apps you got to
get I can't make it but you got the gift
did you go actual invitation to a teller
verbal invite verbal what about Rogan
actually invitable yeah because then you
got to ask for his address and all that
right right yeah that invitation stuff
was a nightmare and Comics are so hard
to pin down well that's also that's what
I wanted to talk it's because we're a
Shifty Bunch by Nature yes right we're
not good at planning we're you know has
anybody been like uh has anybody tried
to bring an extra person too yeah oh
yeah hey I'm seeing this I'm trying to
like I'm trying to bang this broad yeah
can I bring her in really wow her yeah
Stavros
uh he's coming no I'm just kidding but
we had a guy do that I had a bachelor
party in Florida we went all out sure I
saw one guy brought an extra guy just
like randomly he shows up he does this
movie shows up with the guy and he goes
do you guys mind is it cool if Steve's
here
holy [__] but he eventually he did Bert
by the way no no no uh he the other guy
did so much blowing went to the hospital
so we lost him anyway really
he went to the hospital like it's night
two so that kind of took care of itself
you bring an extra guy on top of that
you bring a [__] bubble Gummer what
the [__] kid can't hold his [__]
but yeah so the wedding's gonna be it's
gonna be nuts nice you're doing tucks
are you doing suit I'm going because
you're a little fashionable now you're
all right you do okay okay you play it
down but you do you're good looking kid
you got tight body you dress nice what
are you talking about well this is all
free this is a burger joint my friend
zone
that's like the free gift yeah I love a
good friend yeah you do like the first
wedding to be sponsored by sheath
underwear
Robert Patton yeah the veil is pink camo
yeah everybody gets a manscape how many
Grammy groomsmen how many bridesmaids
keeping it easy she's doing the
traditional I don't I think marriage is
silly I think it's Antiquated I'm doing
it that's nice to say the week of your
wedding yeah look we've had a long talk
about it I don't even get what the gays
want to do with it but uh sure she uh
she's going she understands and she's
got her friends and sister and I just
got my brother as best man he'll do it
so she's gonna have a row and it's just
YouTube
I feel a lot of people are doing that
now because the guys are going like I
don't [__] yeah and it gets
competitiony people are like why didn't
he pick me and you know Comics are we're
all fickle and insecure so just going
with the brother and uh
no speeches no nothing no speech no
religions no speeches no religion yeah
who's marrying you Sean Patton nice yeah
he's officiated he'll he'll do his thing
but so there's no best man speech at the
at the dinner uh the rehearsal not the
rehearsal oh at the reception well
typically there are speeches at like a
standard normal rehearsal people do give
speeches the rehearsal they're really
easy rehearsal dinner yeah really when I
go to like the weddings of my non-comic
normal career friends there's always
people give speeches are you having a
rehearsal dinner the night before we are
but it's just a it's a fish fry that's
fun and a crab boil it's New Orleans the
families know each other they like each
other they get along all that stuff we
got the parents to meet up what's the
scariest thing a month ago and it was it
went well but it was boy it was awkward
that was the first time they've met yeah
well it's you know Boston New Orleans
and they're old so they're not really uh
doing a lot of traveling yeah yikes but
it was awkward but they everything went
well and then they all [__] on Trump and
that like brought him that brought some
kind of uh bonding find a common enemy
yeah is he invited uh Trump got Don Jr
there well we might need more blow bring
me Yak Arena
what's going on with president's sons
and then they're all I mean you got to
think about it they grow up super rich
kids rich kids have no responsibility
you know right they just get to do
whatever they want party the whole nine
yards yeah I remember these videos of
Hunter Biden doing crack with the
hookers and I some of those are wild
wild and I remember thinking like first
I'd love to hang with this guy this guy
it looks like a real good car I know
that wasn't that was a crazy amount of
cocaine a lot of coke it was so much
coke the camera was even blurry it was
like you know it was like that it was
like going back to like 15 years ago
black heavy rocks dude yeah heavy Rock
bring the scale that's what I know you
got a problem I know and uh
but the whole time I'm like why is he
filming this
is
yeah he's not thinking so there you go
to jerk off to jerk off to it later yeah
that's what I would assume probably yeah
yeah we filmed the bachelor party and we
quickly deleted that yeah I saw man's
was there yeah he was filming everything
with Bert right after that okay shout
out to Vance man's arms Good Egg you
guys done everything you know like he
holds like World Records yeah she's it's
like crazy he's the man I mean he's a
he's a known pedophile but he's the man
five bucks a cup have you thought about
a honeymoon yeah you're not gonna like
it uh hold on let's see if we can guess
you'll never guess in a Million years
we're going to Wuhan
it's so nice
a guy like you now you got you guys are
saying it will never guess so all right
tahiti's out Hawaii's out all you travel
a lot I see you on vacation you guys go
Europe's out I would assume Sanford San
Francisco now the U.S I would say the
U.S Nashville hack nothing hack no Paris
no Hawaii oh that's out Puerto Rico
that's still the U.S yeah Ukraine you
going to Kiev
not front lines man not bad not bad is
it Europe no Thailand no did you get
some like crazy baller Suite in New York
so like sometime it's not the US it's
not Europe you're not taking a cruise
are you dude no come on I kind of want
to do one you going to space
South it's not South America nope
Antarctica no no that would be Finland
no Sweden no Africa oh
going to Cape Town
Cape Town now how about this Tanzania
Cape Town we're going to South Africa
Cape Town Johannesburg one of those and
then we're gonna do it up beaches
restaurants the whole thing zip up to
Kenya for the Safari nice well here's my
thinking my buddy we were that that's
gonna be our next patreon goal well if
we when we hit ten thousand well we get
ten thousand pictures we're going on so
far dude we can't wait whoa we were
scared
hear ye hear ye let's talk about
established titles once again my friends
one square foot of Scottish land you
could be called a lord or a lady pretty
sweet guys and let's be neighbors baby
the first 200 people purchased a title
pack using our link will effectively be
next to our plots within a few walking
distance we can start a small army a
garbage out there in Scotland and take
over let's do it yeah let's do it uh
like the Big Man City get at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in Edelson Scotland with
an official certificate and Crest your
certificate has a plot number so you can
see the location of your land it's a
great last minute gift for a loved ones
uh they even have couple packs of you
and the lady are you and your bands or
whoever can join a plot of land it's
fantastic and makes an amazing last
minute gift Savage titles is currently
running a Black Friday sale plus if you
use the code garbage you'll get an
additional 10 off go to establish
titles.com garbage to get your gifts now
and help support the channel do it yeah
okay let's talk about honey honey baby
gang today's episode is sponsored by our
good friends at honey it's the easy way
to save When shopping on your iPhone or
computer save a little ghee baby there
you go we love online shopping but it
happened to all of us you shop it online
the cart's full you go to hit Buy
then they ask you do you have a promo
code you got nothing taunting you it's
looking at you like a bozo but thanks to
Honey searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies to the best
ones that fit your card guys it's
fantastic I would I fought it for a long
time because I'm not a tech guy and then
they became a sponsor it's seriously
that easy you're checking out it pops up
I just bought a pair of shoes you're
checking out it pops up because you want
to apply this 10 coupon you go the [__]
I do baby let's go save me some cake
let's go uh it's fantastic uh I love
honey and you will too I never go
shopping without it everything on my
computer Bing Bang Boom runs through
honey they save it if there's sometimes
there's nothing that's whatever but if
there's something they get you baby they
find it for you uh did you know honey
doesn't just work on your desktop it
works on your iPhone too just activated
on Safari for your phone and save on the
go if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and supporting the podcast we never
recommend something that we don't use
it's true so go get honey for free at
joinhoney.com garbage at joinhoney.com
garbage do it yeah I think this is
fantastic also it's like you've been I
don't know what formed all over the
world exactly you know so it's like
you've done Europe it's like well yeah
European China then Mexico then uh
Puerto Rico I've performed everywhere
Hawaii Kentucky yeah of course still
think about San Fran though all right
all right yeah you can chill on the
sidewalks what's the what's the what's
the beach scene like uh in in Cape Town
and uh beautiful yeah there's a lot of
money down there too oh yeah yeah it's a
little dicey there's a lot of pickpocket
and the apartheid stuff was awkward but
uh it's everybody Raves about how pretty
it is and how developed it is and then
you can fly right up to to [__] real
nature and see a giraffe we were talking
about where are we doing Tunisia
Tanzania hey that's my cousins out there
I love it that's that's out there baby
do it man that you two guys on a safari
I mean it's like a Marx Brothers movie
that'll be great they're gonna be riding
this guy
there's there's people from like Norway
taking pictures of him yeah put down the
other on the other gun
that's my partner yeah that's Foley
oh that's gonna be awesome nice that's
awesome that's really [__] cool man
is that right after the wedding you
going no no we're gonna I'm such a [__]
I've booked all these gigs yeah he
doesn't like taking off yes all right so
how long is this because that's a that's
a long way to do like a weekend you know
what I mean you don't fly 18 hours going
on President's Day for four day weekend
well I got off Monday technically it's a
bank holiday what uh what are you
thinking we're thinking you know uh 13
12 days something like that which there
you go it's gonna I'm gonna be twitching
on day three but you know finding the
monkeys hey have you ever heard anything
yeah will you do any spots over there
well Monroe Martin uh told me about a
hot room also from a business standpoint
you do a little dance over there she's a
write-off you got that right Baby Take
It Go Pro film some stuff put it up on
uh something oh yeah you can write that
all off baby that's good so that'll be
fun I think he's gonna write it off
anyway yeah I'll find something yeah
I'll write one bit out there and I'll
tweet it yeah you like podcasts on yeah
all right that's great man
congratulations awesome appreciate it a
lot of guys are giving me [__] about it
you know you tell Comics anything and
they're like oh I can't get the [__] out
of here I'm like when else would I go of
course yeah
that's a [__] awesome [__]
honeymoon I know well you know God
they're like you gotta go there's a
great bar in Cincinnati I'm like what
the [__] is that Cincinnati
of course I do think there's a thing I
think it comes with age a little bit too
like as we get older and like I mean
you've been [__] doing comedy in New
York for how long 15 years or yeah oh
yeah so it's like you've earned it you
know what I mean it's like you've
traveled all over the world you've
[__] busted your ass it's like yeah
take 11 days with your wife on your
honeymoon yeah doing theaters baby what
do you mean the next marriage I'll go
somewhere else
save a couple of bucks right Ah that's
great that's good stuff congratulations
thank you man we're very happy for you
happy about the tour
thanks guys wait you're married I'm
married yeah any advice
it's a lot
I mean you've been together for a while
living together right sure yeah same
[__] right I talked to a comma glass
then I'm not gonna say who he's like
once I got married it all changed like
think she got weirder she got more
insistent on this and that and I was
like oh no so I had a I had a moment
with my lady don't go change it yeah I
went straight to the house and I was
like we gotta talk and I told her
everything and she was like no don't
worry so no it is it is
awesome it is it's the same spots and
ran right home yeah I did
it was scary there was a little thing or
two of like it just kind of sets in like
the you know foreverness of it sure oh
this you know we have to figure this out
now because
it's not like you can just like walk
away I mean yeah essentially Ken you
know if you don't want to get divorced
no no no she's a great gal I'm very
lucky and uh of course of course
everybody happens yes
um nice all right well this is Let's see
we gotta get we got to get to a couple
of questions
great it's awesome
um all right let's see here guys so as
you know uh when you sign up for patreon
we will answer your garbage question on
the air it's just the best way to do it
we get a lot of submissions but this is
the best way uh so stop hitting us up on
Instagram because they ain't gonna make
it
um this one's from Joseph Smith's wife
number 12. is having your house and
property back against a local country
club or Golf Course classy or trashy I
feel it can go either way usually those
people are they get their their members
it depends if the house is like also on
the property yeah the condos and stuff
like that like yeah my aunt has a window
in South Carolina that's on a golf
course that's different than just living
next to a golf like where De Niro lived
in a casino they were up against a golf
course that's class that's class but it
also depends are you rivaling them like
oh they won't let me in so we're getting
an above ground well yeah I've been on
golf I used to work at a golf course and
you know there was some properties where
you're like oh you
there hasn't been a guy back here with a
weed whacker and you know four months
that was the house that was there before
the golf course exactly that's what I
would say is probably track on the trash
here could be on the track if you were
smart you would take that [__] and run
with them I never understand when
[__]
um that people give pushback on [__]
like that if you [__] take care of
your backyard that's gonna raise your
[__] property value I completely
agree right front yard too you might
catch a Titleist while you're [__]
mowing the lawn yeah
and I'm sure the country club went to
him and said hey we're building can we
have this and some old guy was like this
is I've been here 28 years yeah yeah the
hold off so [__] that self sometimes
they get paid but sometimes they go [__]
that and they just like build around
them or whatever yeah just kind of
screwed you know right and you're living
in the middle a whole 17 or whatever
yeah there's a white trash Temple right
in the middle of the golf course Golf
Course isn't that trashy the the biggest
one is and I had uh I had my cousins
lived there for a while next to a
cemetery oh it was the backyard then a
cemetery talk about I'm out of there
early from dinner
goodbye I'm not a big ghost guy like you
know whatever but like that would give
me the heebie-jeebies a little bit
that's not a positive energy of like
walking by dead people it's always a
chain link fence too it's never a nice
fence chain link fence yeah chain link
fence is a bad look though put some ivy
on that [__] cover that up something so
you got you guys are PA yeah yeah so did
you guys grow up with Woods uh yeah in
certain like not in my Nate but like uh
yeah close like we would go to the woods
like you and just get lost like you know
that's where you smoke cigs that's where
you find porn that's where you [__]
build a tree house not like Forest but
like uh they were kind of I mean my
neighbor clean neighborhoods between
neighbors like patches you wouldn't get
lost in there but you could get you
could disappear in there whoa that's
that's a nice treat for a kid it would
be like a 10-15 minute walk through the
woods into another neighborhood or like
a creek or whatever or they might lead
into like bigger woods and [__] like
that that's fast I was such a city kid I
didn't I was scared of the woods yeah
but you guys are looking at porn in
there we had to go find weird basements
or something well there was always like
the the you know the neighborhood urban
legends too of like there's some sort of
satanic devil worshipers that meet there
my buddy's older brother saw them or
whatever that kind of [__] there was
some weird [__] there'd be like a hot
there'd be like a half burned down house
back there maybe like a weird like rock
formation with like satanic [__] and
stuff like that but they were just
there was so there was this set of Woods
next to my buddy's house where we were
probably like 12 or 13 12 or whatever
we'd go back and like we built like a
tree fort and we would jump into the
water like it was like over like uh what
freak or whatever it was great it was
really cool it was really cool I still
can't wrap my head around what your
neighborhood looked like I know what it
looks like from uh Miller's Crossing yes
but that's that's my house I know that
looks like a Suburban neighborhood to me
no I mean they were big it's a row of
bigger houses but it was all they were
all like kind of dilapia is it like La
so if I walked out of that neighborhood
it would be more urban it'd be City
yeah for sure really I mean I lived
eight uh six blocks from the French
Quarter oh so you walked so realized and
you're in it yeah oh [__] yeah yeah
there's no Woods there there's no yeah
yeah yeah no having some Woods was all
right I bet corn stash yeah we had an
old black guy named Forest that was like
the closest we got
yeah porn was pretty good though but we
did find the one time uh uh it was it
wasn't six feet deep but it was the size
of a coffin
with like the fresh dirt on the side of
it and we walked by it we were cutting
through this way to get to a buddy's
house or whatever and we stumbled upon
like what exactly looked like an open
grave
uh what the we all like panicked yeah we
were still there for like a minute and
we're like What do we do do we come back
and we just kind of like shut that area
of the woods off forever wow I don't
want to go over there and find a buried
like find it covered up and then I gotta
go to the cops or whatever yeah
staying out of it let's go find some
cigs or something yeah cops yeah could
have been a mob hit or something like
that maybe they didn't kill him in Bucks
County Pennsylvania maybe maybe you
don't know that's why they buried Maury
the watch throw them out there or he had
no idea how close the game be getting
whacked we had a house like a half
burned down house in one in one of the
woods very Blair Witch and it was
[__] frightening also that [__]
dropped when I was that age I was like
13 or whatever so that [__] the woods at
that point you go [__] that I was in my
20s and that scared the [__] out of it
oh yeah I hate that [__] Paranormal
Activity all that I love those movies
but they scare me yeah you [__] with The
Conjuring at all no that's too much
you can't do it with it I don't want to
be scared I don't like horror movies no
I don't get it I don't like broncosm
[__] Matt Damon or somebody somebody
give me a guy yes maybe I was too scary
for you yeah that I can deal with
midnight run
hmm
whatever happened to that guy I think he
passed away
um all right this one's from Howie his
full name is Howie felter snatch and it
took me a minute it took me a minute to
put that together
Kanye's lawyer
is it garbage to tuck your ears up into
your baseball hat oh yes good question I
never got that move man that's weird yes
weird yeah that's up there with the
sunglasses up backwards on the neck
that's not a great look either which I
found myself doing just in uh like
moments of like I need like sure I don't
want to put them down I'm like all right
I'll do that and I'm like [__] I'm the
guy yeah I guess if I'm like doing
something I'm like [__] I'm the guy with
them on the back when I was a kid the
only one that did that with the ears
under the under the baseball hat was the
kid that was managing the team you know
what I mean uh you know playing Slowpoke
yeah playing the ball boy got it go
don't you become a thing in uh you know
the hip-hop uh scene guys would and then
when the fitteds became cool they would
wear big ones and Tuck their ears yeah
yeah no good not nice and I'm not crazy
about the flat beak either I like the
beak bent down I completely agree I
think it's The Honky in US yeah
back in the day we would do like it was
like you'll buy a hat and you go well
how are you gonna do it you take like a
Snapple bottle and wrap like rubber
bands they don't really [__] it was
like my brother was good at him yeah did
you do mine please you know it was
almost like a catcher's mitt where you
had to [__] really work and work the
edges yeah yeah yeah we were kids when
the member of the college uh yes I can't
think of the name hats yeah oh Cox was
big yeah I can't think of the name of
the [__] company but yeah one of
those all worn in bent down yeah that
was big and see I'm from Louisiana so we
had a guy with a fish hook he'd put that
on the bill and that was cool it was
just like the generic text yes those
were here they were [__] huge all the
guys are getting laid in in New Orleans
are wearing those
the game they were called yeah that look
at that one the Hoover makes those these
yeah yeah they're called the game I
think peckers yeah yeah men's the game
white yeah the Gamecocks was huge I got
cleaned up for five years whatever it
was those were big yeah Fish Hook and
then there was a thing with lighters
Fish Hook was Big Fish Hook was big you
put fish hooks in there yeah just on the
bills we see people come to the shows
that still have oh really well like if
you're on the south or whatever they'll
have or you know a little more hickey
spot they have uh they have the fish
hook on it yeah yeah huh I never noticed
that and the lighter is taking a lighter
up well once a lighter is done you could
take the metal off and Clank it right
onto the bill that was big too yeah like
the the Kate the outside case yeah like
you can take off exactly you can clamp
that I think I've seen that that makes
sense never seen that um
all right let's see this one's from Dave
Smith uh yeah you wouldn't see a yamaka
with a fish hook that's that's not
happening I can't well maybe a white
fish hook uh all right
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody hits uh this is from Dave
Smith do you know any woman who says
suck my dick yeah that's a tough love
for every girl in Philly yeah suck my
dick yeah why don't you suck my dick it
is a little
that's nice when a girl hits you with
that or calls you a [__] right when a
woman calls out you a [__] man that
really steals the soul out of you I got
a I got a lady on the road I couldn't
get it up and she called me the old
[Laughter]
holy [__] yeah yeah well hey look we
could all be toxic it's not just men
okay of course of course oh man
um all right let's see here this one's
from Steve new 20 homie in the UK what's
up buddy uh is it garbage to buy cigs
from the duty-free shop at the airport
then sell them for profit to people when
you return home of course that's good I
always think of that like my brain works
in the sense I go like what's it
normally called I can get it I like a
good deal yes no this guy's an
entrepreneur good for him I think it's
even trashier if someone's going so hey
you wanna I'm going to Ohio or I'm going
to Delaware or I'm going to whatever you
want me to get you to pick you up a
carton right I'll pick you up a carton
let me get you a card I'm getting a
carton you want a carton I don't like
the cartons no it's too much it's too
much man I know I'm gonna [__] cross
through 20 packs of heaters exactly I
used to do it when we moved to New York
I would go home every now and then sigs
were at the time like six seven six
seven bucks in Philadelphia but here
they were 15 like 14 and as a super poor
comic you're like oh yeah I'm like if
you're smoking you know a couple packs a
week I'm like this is 50 bucks that I
don't have on top of what I'm already
willing to spend do you still smoke
ah nah I quit uh but skank Fest was a
tough I bet skank fest with a couple of
beers wide open at the tables you could
smoke inside
that's also too those things you know a
lot of us all have anxiety and stuff
like that so it's like you're in the
green room like I don't know anybody I'm
like I'm gonna go smoke like that's what
I do with social I'm like I'm gonna go
smoke and then I'm out there and I go
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and then I
go I'm gonna get a beer I'm just like
constantly doing those three things did
you ever smoke I have somewhere like
smoke smoke nah I tried it once and I
didn't I didn't get it I tried it once I
just stick I hit the hit the you know
the cancer stick one time and I was like
okay I don't get it not for me what
about a cigar cigar I love you do yeah I
mean once a month I'm not one of these
guys who's smoking bats every night
these guys a couple of sticks yeah yeah
but I do enjoy one every now and then
but the cigs I don't know not for me but
I get it I like it I like the look of it
I get it's romantic but yeah no doobies
right you don't smoke weed no no I do
the gums
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thing you know you're not just standing
there like a dope sure but then it also
does open the door of like you go out to
smoke a cig and then you're like all
these crazy anybody can get you now at
this point you're just whoever's out
there you're like well these are my
friends for four minutes type thing yeah
that's so fun that's worse than the
cancer
awkward conversation yeah
um all right let's do a couple more here
this was from Jack Van delay
from vandaling Industries
have you or anyone you know ever hired a
private investigator
which is a home run of a question good
one because that's never good no no no
no it's either like really poor [__] or
like you know very high-end corporate
against like just call cheaters what do
you do unless you get the screen time
right have you ever done that no but I I
like the pi I I relate to that I respect
them yeah the pizza boxes the beer cans
are in shirt yeah I like that doesn't
start all the time he's a road cop he's
a road comic yeah he lives in the studio
come on
he comes back to you with shitty stuff
he's like so she likes uh peaches he's
got bad [__] yeah he's bad he's
bouncing premises right right
I like that guy though Mr Jenkins yeah
he's down and out he's on his own he's
looking for a win usually an ex-cop yeah
got ran out off the force for some
reason yeah cops look at him like we
look at Tick-Tock Comics you know we're
like ah you're not doing the real thing
get out of here where's your bed yeah
yeah I was giving him [__] that's funny
that's really good
um all right this one's from Daniel 10
homie here uh is it garbage to haggle
With a Stripper yes man stop with that
[__]
I've done it I've done it sometimes they
do open the door yes right uh you know I
was recently at an establishment
uh and they open up the thing and if you
say they're like hey it's only a hundred
dollars I'm like you know I forgot what
the number was and you go no they go how
about 70 I go well now you've opened the
door right to some negotiation how about
15. yeah
how about six inches that's six this
guy's like what do you want porn star
but no I'm I think that is crazy but I
have done it and also like there is not
a price tag on it like yeah there you
know there is things open for
interpretation a little bit it's awkward
because you're basically saying she's
like hey 50 bucks and you're like look
at you yeah come on 50 you're not 50.
that's tough so that's why it's hard but
it's about I got a coupon lady what are
you talking about my mom sent it to me
how about a coupon for a free slime now
you're doing a checkbook with a project
I think haggling at a rub and tug is
worse that that's you should just go
like whatever it is it is I'm here but
especially they have control of your
joystick ah the youngest let me give you
a [__] good point good point and
she's gonna be greasing her Palm
grease and they shoot a little bit
all right let's see here half off but no
lube uh I just found a private
investigator in New York who seems to
sit and most of his time yelling at
people who give him one star reviews on
Google that's fun
TV show that's all right that's a show
that's all right now it says here you
gave me one star
after I found your dead wife what the
[__]
uh Michael McKeever is Biz dude but
let's be honest in his defect if you
could give cops a rating they'd be
[__] well you can rank I think on Yelp
or whatever like Google reviews like you
can go to like the precinct really in
the neighborhood I think if you're in
just like pull up Google Maps and it'll
say like NYPD Precinct whatever whatever
other reviews I think people are like I
went here because my cat was stuck in a
tree that's hilarious I Think Jesus
really well they have a monopoly you
know there's no competition break it up
well you're the police what do you mean
it's got our own police force hey Uber
did it cab sucks check this out one star
review from Captain Jen Miller would not
accept my offer or locate my old lover
whoa to which Mr Michael McIver responds
you should be embarrassed Captain Jim
the real issue is you didn't want to pay
and you know it
this guy's awesome this guy's all right
yeah get him on besides trying to use
the doubtful Captain claim he's taking
shots at his rank plus he doesn't plus
he doesn't do uh he doesn't do creeper
jobs
find my ex-lover that sounds real
suspicious yeah let it go man she's a
[__] yeah no [__]
uh who was it I think it was uh Nathan
for you did a
he hired a private investigator to find
himself
yeah he had a bunch of guys look like
him like leave that that's brilliant
that guy's awesome
Mr Beast did a similar thing too was
like if you can catch me I'll give you a
million dollars or whatever that guy's
crazy oh yeah he's got the money to burn
um all right let's do one more then we
gotta wrap her up here uh this one's
from Dave are you garbage if you still
look under the cap of a 20 ounce bottle
to see if you want anything oh that was
big
I remember taking off the little blue
the little blue thing to see if you can
read the code exactly that would make my
blood run cold and my nail would get
like under it I need a pair of tweezers
oh yeah oh yeah that was like taking the
the nipple uh what do you call those
things clamps no [__] boobs cut this you
know the nipple on a stripper she had uh
thank you sorry I don't think I've ever
taken a pair of pasties off but girls
wear those now they have the little
yeah so they can go no bra ah I like
their you know their antennas aren't out
keep the girls free I think I like an
antenna but they don't like it they
don't like they know that you like the
antenna and shut down smart all right
that's nice restaurants
blueberries that doorbell yeah
have you ever won anything like that a
contest any sort of uh giveaway I've won
like a freak another free code free
ticket or whatever still that was big
you know but there was a lawsuit and you
can give this a goog there hug but there
was a lawsuit about a guy and drank a
Diet Coke threw it away the janitor
found it had the cap one million dollars
and they had to fight over it really I
think the janitor won because at that
point it's like no longer your I mean
but he's it's a chicken in the egg kind
of a Solomon cut the baby it sounds like
a case for the private investigator yeah
get Captain Jim on it get the big guy on
I would split it at that point yeah
offer to split it I don't know man I
guess the general 500g I found this it's
like the abortion argument you know is
it your cap when it you bought it or is
it you know so who's who's the winner
I'm not raising that cap I'll tell you
that much
it's my brother's soda I can't yeah
ladies and gentlemen Mr Mark Norman
thank you Cedar tour tickets
marknormancomedy.com hey hey we might be
drunk Tuesdays with stories anything
else you want the folks out there to
know uh you know I got a Netflix
thingamajiggy I got a YouTube special
called out to lunch let's pop that puppy
up to 11 mil we're right there
tell a friend follow me on all the
Cleaves if you're not familiar are you I
mean I myself of course they are if
you're not he's the [__] one of the
funniest hardest working com I mean it's
it's wild go check them out if you've
been living under a rock you bozos
absolute killer buddy we love you thank
you for coming
what do you got for him guys we're all
over the road as well we have a uh I
think like 10 shows left for the end of
the year get tickets to those Boston the
second show is probably sold out Philly
sold out Rhode Island there's a few
tickets left to the second show I think
Atlanta's got a little bit left in the
first show okay
come see us down here in Charlotte get
those tickets pick up the card game card
game might still be available oh yeah
that was fun if not that might be out
just you know everything's in the
description check it out we love you
guys
do it sorry well Digger Cat spirit do
yourself a favor Taiwan on
[Music]
praise Allah